liebe zuschauer und schon wieder erleben
wir gemeinsam eine woche für die
geschichtsbücher der bundespräsident hat
angela merkel am dienstag die
entlassungsurkunde überreicht eine muss
man so sagen historische zäsur sie ist
zwar noch ein paar wochen
geschäftsführendem abend klar wird aber
schon bald mehr zeit zu hause verbringen
mit ihrem mann professor sauer und ich
finde es ist schön dass
das sei ihr von herzen gegönnt soll uns
meine damen und herren aber bitte nicht
ablenken von der eigentlichen meldung
der woche nicht nur die kanzlerin ist
entlassen worden ein auch einer der
wichtigsten freien mitarbeiter dieser
sendung ist entlassen worden an die
scheuer eben noch verkehrsminister jetzt
im toten winkel der opposition was für
ein absturz dafür haben wir ihn als
dritten politiker überhaupt feierlich
aufgenommen in die heute-show hall of
fame für die besten sendezeit
lieferanten davor brennt ein
symbolischer hoffen steuergeld
die installation heißt maut
sie hörten unseren letzten meine das
wirklich historischer moment lieber an
die wir werden dich bald vergessen aber
er bleibt ja einfacher abgeordneter im
20ten deutschen bundestag dem größten
bundestag den wir je hatten wow
736 abgeordnete wiener verdammten
legebatterie vielen dank noch mal an die
csu die wirklich alles gegeben hat meine
echte wahlrechtsreform zu verhindern war
aber trotzdem eine schöne erste sitzung
hier sämtliche highlights es ist ganz
schön voll hier unten oder ja also ganz
schön gruselig friedrich merz mit julia
klöckner jetzt haben wir doch ein
breites spektrum an gesichtern hier ein
gut gelaunter armin laschet muss man
sagen ja man sieht dann seinen online
wolfgang kubicki der
petra pau über den rücken streichern
rohleder der sg kleenheim
desinteressiert dahinter ein was für ein
prachtvoller strauß
799 an der tanke ja immerhin ist der
bundestag jetzt etwas diverser und etwas
jünger 47 abgeordnete unter 30 es geht
fast schon in den bereich
kindertagesstätte das ist ja da
verändert sich ein bisschen was außerdem
gibt es mehr frauen
34,7 prozent frauenanteil sehr gut denn
das entspricht ja exakte im realen
geschlechterverhältnisse haben noch zwei
drittel männer und ein drittel frauen
süße sag ich doch wobei die neuen frauen
fast nur bei spd und grünen sitzen die
union bleibt betont männlich quasi auf
dem boden der tatsachen
ja muss man dazu sagen weil sie da halt
frauen technisch einfach auch schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht haben um merkel
programm karrenbauer frau von der leyen
hatten ja alles frauen die auch sehr
mächtig sind die auch die aktuelle lage
ein stück weit mit zu verantworten haben
deswegen glaube ich dass wir jetzt
gerade
denke ich andere probleme haben als
frauen themen
bleiben wir haben es doch versucht mit
den doofen mädchen
gucken wo sie uns hingebracht hat
position ja das ist trauerarbeit auf
testosteron trotzdem behaupte ich ist
die östrogene sierung der deutschen
politik gar nicht mehr aufzuhalten jetzt
kriegt der bundestag stellen sie sich
das mal vor schon die dritte weibliche
präsidentin in nur 70 jahren das ist
wahnsinn fragen sie bärbel bas von der
spd und
wenn sie jetzt fragen berdel was das ist
tatsächlich glauben sie mir eine sehr
kompetente
gesundheitsexperten ich meine aus
duisburg ich komme aus duisburg bin ja
in duisburg auch viele unterwegs jetzt
habe ich in duisburg das glück duisburg
wo ich geboren bin ich habe sicherlich
so meine eigene art manchmal vielleicht
auch ein bisschen ruhrgebiets charme und
ich könnten port kann man nicht ändern
aber ich trotzdem knoller nicht dass
unser bärbel kuschinski
die eurozone ich sage ihnen da kann sich
vor allem die afb warm anziehen wenn
frau was bald die debatten leitet die
afd deren kandidat für den vize-posten
zum siebten mal durchgefallen ist das
ist ja einerseits ganz lustig
andererseits könnte das ritualisierte
fernhalten der afg von solchen ämtern
der partei am ende mehr nutzen als
schaden wenn es durchläuft futter für
den opfermythos genau wie die tatsache
wissen sie bestimmt dass keiner mehr
neben der afg sitzen will ja der der
sitz krieg
der sitz krieg wurde erklärt die fdp
sagt leute wir können nicht mehr neben
der afg sitzen wir haben tinnitus es
geht nicht mehr die union soll jetzt
gefälligst neben die rechten rutschen
hier bei der konstituierenden sitzung
diese woche hatten übrigens 23 hfc ja
erst mal oben auf der so genannten
solchen tribüne
ja weil sie sich nicht mal testen lassen
wollten ist doch prima überlegen sie mal
die afg hat er endlich einen eigenen
vip-bereich toll wirklich für
[Applaus]
eigenen bereich für sagen wir mal
speziell begabte abgeordnete die neue
alternative mit etwas weniger sitzen
dafür aber deutlich völkischer und
nationaler da ist zum beispiel matthias
helferich aus nrw der selbst im eigenen
laden wohl einen tick zu radikal ist
denn im sommer wurde ein älterer zeit
bekannt in dem er sich unter anderem als
das freundliche gesicht des
nationalsozialismus bezeichnet so der
nationalsozialismus hat jetzt ein
freundliches gesicht wenn das der führer
erfährt dann ist aber was los und auch
für solche jets fliegt man natürlich
nicht raus bei der ft ist klar er ist
jetzt vorübergehend fraktionslos ich sag
mal so von dem bisschen bürgerlichen
tarnanstrich den die partei vielleicht
mal hatte ist im neuen bundestag nicht
mehr viel zu sehen neu dabei etwa ein
vom militärischen abschirmdienst als
extremist eingestufter soldat ein
suspendierter polizist und neulinge die
der sogenannten querdenker bewegung
nahestehen betrug mischung warte mal ein
soldat ein polizist da fehlt jetzt nur
noch der cowboy der bauarbeiter und
schäfer und wir haben die rechten
village people meine damen und herren
ohr
43 afd abgeordnete zählt man inzwischen
zum bernd hocke flügel da ist es kein
wunder dass keiner neben den sitzen will
am ende entscheidet übrigens der
sogenannte ältestenrat des bundestages
ob die liberalen mit ihrer forderung
durchkommen und plätze tauschen dürfen
mit der union wir schalten wir live zu
tina hausten in den bundestag tina was
passiert dann auch zu dieser späten
stunde tja und jetzt haben wir den salat
der sitzplatz krieg eskaliert total sie
sehen sie hinter mir ein fdp
abgeordneter hat einfach dreist ein cdu
platz in der ersten reihe okkupiert und
sagt jetzt erkennt nicht mehr weg
kindergarten also wirklich tja und jetzt
müssen die anzahl diener sehen wie sie
das problem lösen
ach es ist alles ziemlich würdelos
also
holly war ich kann ihnen sagen natürlich
natürlich versteht man die position der
fdp niemand will neben der afg sitzen
ich sag mal den affenfelsen ebenso guckt
man sich gerne an aber ich habe mich da
ich ja nicht mit traurigen
rekord bei den ordnungsrufen in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode
das waren mehr als in den vier perioden
davor zusammen nicht man in der kantine
ist man sicher den ein mitarbeiter der
afg fraktion oder eines fdp-abgeordneten
nimmt war das ein anderer ein
vegetarisches gericht bestellt darauf
kommt die bemerkung euch kriegen wir
auch noch ihr körnerfresser
das ist nicht nett nicht schön
andererseits welche essen bestellen bis
natürlich auch eine provokation
leider hat die fdp mit ihrem tausch
wunsch die büchse der pandora geöffnet
und da gucken sie mal die ersten
abgeordneten sie servieren abends ihre
plätze und handlich das ist deprimierend
und wie geht der streit jetzt aus keine
ahnung aber es herrscht nackte anarchie
die linken wollen nicht mehr neben den
grünen sitzen weil die gemeine sachen
über punkte haben und ständig irgendwas
mit lauch drin essen und bei der cdu
gibt es wohl einen neuen abgeordneten
neben dem wir gar keiner sitzen und zwar
ist das wohl ein gewisses armin laschet
nie gehört
ja aber seine kollegen seien er bringt
es ja also man kann sagen die union
erlebt eine regelrechte identitätskrise
ich meine gerade die alten silberrücken
die ewig regiert haben wissen ja gar
nicht was opposition ist was man da
macht wie wir haben sie in letzter zeit
mal den peter ramsauer gesehen wer ist
der
derartig durch den wink der wartet nur
noch das in irgendeiner nach hause
bringt das ist erschreckend
als oliver man kann wirklich nur hoffen
dass der ältestenrat das ganze theater
hier bald beendet und
was etwas leute sorry aber ich habe euch
tausendmal gesagt ich arbeite nicht
neben der treppe von der ard
rtl2 jederzeit kein ding aber nicht die
ard gemacht hat mit journalismus nichts
zu tun
[Musik]
ich könnte stundenlang
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
auslasten abo da